last spring a couple friends of mine
Jack and Hans were having a disagreement
and that disagreement was about buff
spells Jack was insisting that they're
largely pretty bad and a waste of deck
space in just about all formats whereas
Hans was passionately defending them as
an underrated type of card after the
conversation was over Hans looking
intensely off into space simply said I
need to make a buff spells deck now and
in the following weeks he did just that
he went for teamer colors and built it
dirt cheap as it turns out buff spells
are quite inexpensive even the good ones
he started with Paco and Halen as the
commanders which performed roughly as
you'd expect for a $20 buff spells deck
it was a mediocre mid-range Deck with
some funky combat tricks and Paco ate
his fair share of removal spells but
then Hans switched out the commander for
a much spicier Choice zyrus the writhing
storm suddenly the deck started
performing very differently games with
this version of zyrus start off pretty
unassumed ly the deck typically plays a
ramp spell and some sort of value
creature turns two and three and then
plays its Commander turn four or five
from there it typically ramps a bit more
plays another creature or two and hits
the person at the table who is doing the
worst combat step with zyrus generally
sees Hans saying who wants some cards
and then as promised letting a person
he's okay with drawing cards along with
himself draw cards if a player kept a
risky hand and is getting flooded or
screwed zyrus is here to save them to
bestow upon them the gift of three or
six or even nine cards and this is the
Trap the deck lays seeming like a friend
I have seen a Mana screwed player
counter an opposing removal spell that
targets zyrus simply because they were
desperate to keep drawing those cards
the deck is friendly and unassuming
right up until the point where it starts
deciding to stop being those things and
start murdering players because fun fact
letting you and an opponent each draw 15
cards is great when that opponent
simultaneously dies to Commander damage
relevant to the way this deck operates
in practice is the small Bean syndrome
video I made a while back Hans plays the
deck totally straight he doesn't
emphasize the deck's power nor its lack
of power but the deck nonetheless
heavily plays on the perceptions of its
opponents the deck is pretty predictable
if you stop and take a moment to think
about it it's about 20% buff spells 10%
protection spells 10% removal spells and
an assortment of lands ramp and utility
creatures from there when you know how
many cards the deck has drawn you can
guess the approximate composition of its
current hand very little in the deck is
fully unique and if you were to think
about this constantly to realize that
the deck is probably currently holding
multiple protection spells fight spells
and or buff Spells at a given moment and
is going to get escalating numbers of
those things on the coming turns you
might get worried about what the deck is
doing and correctly so but nobody seems
to do this sort of analysis this deck
gets underestimated game after game and
by people who have lost to it half a
dozen or more times even I frequently
find myself underestimating the deck
specifically because individual cards in
the deck aren't very memorable the
deck's lack of spicy plays and absolute
transparency in what it's trying to do
in a given game play to its strengths it
effortlessly slides to the back of its
opponent's mind as the pile of bulk
Commons that will draw them some cards
and it stays there until it's far too
late I say far too late because this
deck operates more or less on the
snowball principle early in the game it
doesn't have many buff spells protection
spells or removal spells however as it
accumulates cards from zyrus hits it has
more and more resources to protect its
game plan and stop other people and by
the time it has killed a player it has
access to basically whatever resources
from its deck that it wants in addition
the threat profile of the deck typically
lags behind its actual power at any
given moment people are usually
concerned about the deck in the amount
they should have been concerned about it
a turn or two
previously however despite not
presenting as a deck the table should be
worried about winning the deck does
cultivate a specific more mundane type
of fear in its opponents a fear created
directly from the act of running a lot
of buff spells the combination of the
deck being 20% buff spells and it
drawing a lot of cards gives an
impression of an endless stream of buff
spells when it comes down to it the deck
supply of buff spells is finite it is
spending resources to use them and it
does run out of them sometimes but the
deck's opponents nonetheless learn to
exist in a con state of fear during the
combat step can I attack the zyrus
player with my 55 trampler no they have
a one- one snake they can block with I
don't want to lose my creature should I
block that cat gist well no of course
not do I look like somebody who throws
my threats in the garbage this might
seem like a minor Factor but like many
other aspects of the deck it's a dynamic
that hinders its opponent's abilities to
work together to slow it down in theory
if a player is far ahead you can make
use of the multiplayer nature of the
format two or more opponents trading
cards one for one as blockers or through
removal spells will wear down a deck
over time and if anything this is more
true in the case of opposing decks
forcing zyrus to use buff spells outside
of dealing combat damage to a player the
deck's happy place is when it pours
three to four buff spells into killing a
player with zyrus and restocking its
hand and every buff spell it uses on
damage not being dealt to an opponent
sets it back from getting to that place
but the impression of a NeverEnding tide
of buff spells paired with the deck's
delayed threat profile keeps opponents
from playing this way in most games the
snakes zyrus creates bolster these
characteristics both the way the deck
discourages its opponents from trying to
engage with it during the combat step
and the snowball Factor zyrus creates a
lot of snakes even if its opponents
aren't running draw of any kind it's
still generating as many snakes as the
commander deals damage to players this
means three per turn at minimum and a
dozen or more per turn once the deck
hits its stride the result of this
compounds with the nature of being a
buff spells deck the deck gains piles
and piles of potential attackers and
blockers that could get larger and gain
all manner of potentially problematic
keywords at any moment this also plays
into the snowball Factor once opponents
catch on to how concerning the deck is
even if they manage to dump enough
removal into the commander to break
through the deck's protection spells
they're still going to have a lot of
snakes to deal with if there are enough
of these snakes they alone could be
adequate to push through for the win as
the benefit of having a wide Board of
attackers means that the deck can pile
buff spells onto the unblocked snakes
effectively creating a sort of evasion
where the deck can decide to have a
specific snake be its scary attacker
after blockers are declared the snake
problem isn't impossible to overcome
though and one good way to shut it down
is to play a board wipe and actually
this can even be a good way to deal with
the deck's Commander as well since of
its 11 cards that could be considered
protective five of them are entirely
useless against board wipes and the
other six are only situationally useful
so are board wipes this decks Achilles
heel kind of but not exactly and to
explain why I need to talk about the
ways decks store accumulated resources
most Commander decks tend to have some
focus on building up resources and a key
question is what the deck does with
those resources to push its Advantage
but also avoid losing them all that key
question's answer is the aeri Kyler
scale of accumulated resource permanency
trademark pending basically Plaines
Walker emblems and experience count ERS
are the most permanent type of resource
as something that opponents literally
can't interact with generally followed
by Lands cards in hand a variety of
different nonl permanence and a single
type of nonl permanent with creatures
whose presence on the board holds up the
deck's entire game plan such as Kyler or
chainer generally being the most
vulnerable way to store resources the
zyrus buff spells deck is among the
Decks that treat cards in hand as their
primary place to store resources but
these decks differ widely with one axis
of difference being especially key
velocity control decks combo decks and a
decent portion of high curved mid-range
decks will place high value on the stuff
they have in their hand but they
generally play that stuff slowly their
turnover of the stuff in their hand is
pretty low an attribute we could call
being low velocity by contrast zyrus
buff spells is a very high velocity deck
buff spells can essentially be thought
of as creatures that only cost a
fraction as much but stick around for a
single turn and in later turns the deck
will often turn through five or more of
these per turn the result of this is
that zyrus buff spells will be somewhat
resilient to board wipes since most of
zyrus' power is stored in the deck's
hand and it can rapidly play them out on
the next turn it has a creature to swing
with however its high velocity also
means that if the deck's draw is cut off
multiple turns in a row or if it loses
zyrus at a moment where it's already low
on Buff spells it will struggle to get
back on its feet quickly with this
weakness in mind I feel I should clarify
what I mean when I call this my play
group's best deck this isn't a deck that
generally Dukes it out with high
powerered combo decks it would have a
hard time in those games no this is a
deck that gets pulled out in low to
medium power games on paper it's hans's
least powerful deck and I think it
shouldn't go understated just how
unassuming this deck seems even having
seen it in action it's mostly bulk
Commons it's pretty dependent on the
commander it's not very fast the Mana
Base is almost entirely basic and tap
lands and its core category of card is
usually relegated to being played in
limited and maybe the fastest of aggro
decks this deck doesn't seem very good
and that perception is exactly what
makes it so good what causes it to win
the vast majority of games It's featured
in the deck absolutely could be improved
in terms of its raw power level
especially with another 20 to $30 in
budget it could run a couple more
counter spells it could run some
protective equipments it could run
better ramp and most importantly it
could run two to three cards that give
unlimited hand size which would on paper
eliminate one of the deck's key
weaknesses but here's the thing doing
those things would turn this deck into a
more generic Voltron deck one that is
obviously threatening and a very visible
ticking Time Bomb for everybody at the
table as long as zyrus is in play I've
argued in the past that reliquary Tower
is overrated and this is a strange case
where it actually would be quite good
from a power level standpoint and yet
it's still correct not to include it
discarding to hand size is the final
Dynamic that causes people to
underestimate the deck if the deck has a
fistful of 10 or 15 or even 20 cards
it's obviously a threat but when you
watch the deck discard back down to
seven you have to ask yourself come on
how good could that hand possibly be and
in this case you wouldn't even be wrong
to ask that there are only so many
protection spells and buff spells and
other types of spells that a seven card
hand can contain and the deck does need
a balance inflicting lethal combat
damage with protecting the commander and
retaining the ability to deal with
opposing threats in this way not running
unlimited hand size cards makes the deck
more interesting to play against and
also more interesting to play in later
turns the discard phase becomes a
critical decision point where the zyrus
player must carefully plan out their
resources and try to navigate around
what their opponents are trying to do
it's like a turn-based boss fight where
the boss needs to carefully aot
resources in order to best ward off the
encroachments of the other players it's
honestly really cool and it's kind of
hard to ever be mad at the zyrus deck
for this reason even as it tends to pull
off wins in the end regardless
paradoxically the zyrus buff spells deck
has the highest win rate of any deck in
my play group because of how Dynamic and
how fair it is the deck is a master
class in playing commander in the purest
sense it does a good job of creating
interesting gameplay for everybody at
the table and that interesting gameplay
itself greatly contributes to its
ability to win
games thanks for watching I had planned
to release a video about navigating
power levels this week but I couldn't
quite get the script where I wanted it
in time so I decided to make this video
instead you can expect that power level
video next week though I will also be
posting an end note to this video
tomorrow over on my patreon that
discusses a particular deck building
style that was used in making this deck
so if you aren't giving me money yet now
is a pretty cool time to start